you play Pokemon [__] when you're a kid
too I used to play Pokemon I tried it
was just too hard to get into like to me
it was oh imagine the action [__] you
we're almost playing video games like
Yu-Gi-Oh and [__] you know yeah when you
came out I was well past it I was
wearing watching too much WWF at that
yeah yeah playing with wrestlers
physical tangible slams so you were like
[__] breaking toys apart like said
never no I took care of mine but I did
full-on wrestling matches uh oh yeah you
still have your little case yeah you're
right he was archiving yesterday yeah he
was he said we're housing them they're
still yeah
oh
what I have Rosie's nephew two of my
toys out of the chest we're all here and
I did not get more Crofton Spider-Man
back oh my God I need my toys back sorry
this is not podcast relevant at all
you get